Hello everyone. Very happy to be with
you. I'm generally seen as the Islam guy
and I talk about that big issue, but
seeing that this is a Christian revival
conference and the fact that Islam and
Christianity, there's something of a
symbiotic relationship going on, I have
to actually talk about both because it's
really all interrelated. And so what I'd
like to start off with when I think of
problems, what's the first things?
What's the first premise at the problem?
And I often think that many people don't
really see it or don't talk about it. We
tend to talk about symptoms. Islam
itself in the West, in Europe, in the
UK, I see it as a symptom. I don't see
it as an inherent or innate problem and
it's a symptom of essentially the
weakening or the dying of Christianity
in the West. So how did that happen? And
one of the thoughts that's been
percolating in my mind and I've been
thinking about and talking about quite
often is the idea that one of the
problems with Christianity in the modern
era is that it has in very many ways
adopted a materialist paradigm, not
unlike atheists and secularists. And by
that, I don't mean materialistic as in
covetous. I mean it in a more
philosophical sense, a materialist
paradigm in the sense that
all [snorts] that is real, let's say
from an atheist point of view, all that
is real is what? It's the material,
right? It's the physical world. It's
what I can see, feel, touch, and
measure. And all this abstract talk
about your morality and your religion
and all this sort of thing is usually
jettisoned and that's one of the
problems, but
I fear and I think and I see that much
of Christianity in all of its
manifestations in the modern era has
adopted this worldview despite the
theological veneer of what they say. So
in other words, a Christian can of
course express profound theological
truisms, but at the same time,
um it, you know, as they say, the proof
is in the pudding. And what I'm seeing
is so how is a Christian becoming a
materialist paradigm in a philosophical
sense? If I speak to a Christian, what
is the greatest evil that you can engage
in? I think a lot of people will say
what a atheist would say, which is
physical harm, okay? Physically harming
someone and much worse, of course,
killing someone.
And I agree, of course, those are great
evils. No one would argue that. But,
unbeknownst to most Christians, that was
actually more of a minor aspect of the
message of Christianity, the entire
ethos, the the morality that was
created. And in short, before I
elaborate, the problem with materialist
Christianity, which in many ways has,
like I said, permeated the worldview of
all Christians, is that it perfectly
comports with secularism and atheism.
And that is why Christianity is still
allowed to live side by side with a
secular or even atheistic world um
environment, because it also agrees all
that we want to do is make sure no one's
physically hurt, there's no violence.
But, the question now becomes what
happened to morality?
That was a word that used to be pivotal
and important and fundamental to
something like Christianity.
Where is what is there morality anymore?
And I'm not talking, of course, about
individual Christians. I'm sure there
are many devout Christians still are in
the world, but it's not something that
is socially acknowledged or something
much less that is socially pursued that
we talk about. Okay, so and once one I
think this is my realization when I
think about it
and how morality is not
is not
Western people and Christians will say
they're moral, but again, it's through a
materialist paradigm. And you know that
by simply looking at what used to be the
greatest sins and the greatest evils for
a society, and all of them are to
various degrees completely accepted for
by Christians today. And all one has to
do is look at the sexual mores of the
West today,
and very few Christians will even argue
or or or talk about it or even dispute
it. And they'd be, of course,
scandalized to feel like they have to
talk about it. But, if you look at
historic Christianity, biblical
Christianity, Christianity in all of its
forms. Something like sexual mores,
sexual sins, that was one of the
pinnacles and the one of the most
unquestioned aspects of Christianity.
So, you see this is why why is it not
being mentioned? Because, well, no one's
hurting anyone. And so, that's what I
mean. That's a perfect example of how a
Christian adopts the materialist
worldview. Now, there used to be
something and um just to make it simple,
you may have heard of I'm sure you have
you have, of course, many Catholics,
Anglicans of the seven deadly sins,
which actually very much informed the
worldview of Christians in the
pre-modern era.
And they are I often miss, but let's
see. Uh wrath, greed, gluttony, envy,
lust, um
sloth.
And I always miss one.
Pride. Oh, yeah, the worst one.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, I know. The root of them all.
Yeah, you're right. Okay.
So, think about those seven things now.
Okay, that is what a Christian society
thought about. Now, these are all
metaphysical. They're not material.
Okay, these were metaphysical
principles. This is what Christianity
was all about. Notice, killing is not
one of the seven deadly sins. Why? Cuz
it's a byproduct. Of course, it's evil
and you shouldn't do it, but it wasn't
seen as a root cause. Now, when I look
at these the seven deadly sins, which
were fundamental to a Christian society,
Christian
um
to Christendom essentially for centuries
up until actually quite recently.
Not only are they not something that we
talk about or something we condemn, they
are in fact what we now celebrate and a
bunch of our economy is based on it.
And we call ourselves Christians and we
live with it and we live in peace with
this. And I find that very interesting.
Pride. Pride, of course, is exalted.
Pride, you know, there's Pride Month.
Think about that. Uh lust, that's
everywhere you look. It's it's it's
promoted. it's it's
glamorized. Envy, just think social
media, okay?
Gluttony,
turn a TV on, everything's about, you
know, putting images of food. Sloth. So,
it's kind of amazing that to me these
are the principal issues. These are the
first things that were actually at the
heart of a Christian order, and they've
just been completely so jettisoned, and
very few Christians even understand
this. And that's the point. This is so
subtle and so incremental that and the
reason is, the best way I can put it is
because Christians one way or the other
over the decades and possibly centuries
have just adopted a very materialist
worldview, which is that yeah, we talk
about the afterlife, we talk about sin,
we talk about being saved, but in the
end, when it comes to society,
the old we begin and end with just not
hurting people, okay?
So, that's become the ultimate Christian
virtue. And it is a virtue, I'm not
arguing that, but I'm trying to say
there was so much more above it, which
actually gave meaning to life.
Now,
what happens when society, such as
Western society, European society,
jettisons what I'm talking about, which
is essentially the metaphysical aspect
of Christianity. You can actually call
it the spiritual aspect, because the the
physical
or material aspect,
what's the corollary to the
metaphysical, the beyond the physical?
Well, that's the spiritual.
And I just think it's funny because a
lot of Christians today, when they say
the word spiritual, it means some sort
of abstract
fuzzy feeling. Actually, I think to be
spiritual is to be engaged and to
comprehend and try to exercise the
metaphysical metaphysical aspects of
Christianity, the things that are beyond
the physical, that are not measurable,
that deal with morals and ethics, and
that sort of thing.
Now, when all that is jettisoned, as it
has been in recent generations,
a vacuum is created, and that's I think
where we are. And what does nature
abhor? It abhors a vacuum. Enter Islam.
Well, Islam of course is its own body of
system. It's its own religion. It has
its own teachings. You know, one can be
very
hostile to it or critical of it. And I'm
of course associated with those views.
But we have to be honest, it also brings
a sort of traditional worldview. It
knows what a woman is and it knows what
a man is. It's not confused about that
for example. And it has all sorts of
things that were very traditional that
Europeans and Christians would have
agreed with historically. So I think
that aspect be And it's confident. So
now you have a vacuum in Europe or in
the West in general because of the
reasons I've I've outlined dealing with
the um
the [snorts] sort of slow melting away
of Christianity based on these
philosophical or epistemological under
underpinnings.
Now you have Islam coming in and it may
have all its problems and all but it's
still it's very visceral, it's
down-to-earth, and it does offer all of
these things that are filling the
vacuum. Okay? And this is why you find
Western people who are turned off and
find no resonance in modern secular
liberal uh culture and they turn to
something like Islam, which on the heart
of it doesn't make any sense. I wager if
those people actually had a true
Christian upbringing or according to the
way I'm trying to describe it, which is
actually much more fused with a
metaphysical understanding, they would
not find Islam appealing. But that's
what I mean. There's a vacuum now so
that even something that is inherently
inferior in as much as it offers
something of a primordial
conservative worldview that still
resonates with all humans, then it
becomes appealing.
And then it's all especially in this
country, it's coalescing in a very
strange way. As you all know now that
there's a new um blasphemy code or uh
about Islam a new anti-Islamophobia or
anti-Islam hostility thing.
And of course, this is just this is that
one more way to help Islam to become
more empowered, more entrenched. You
can't even criticize it. And I haven't
looked as closely as I'd like to the
wording, but it seems it's very fuzzy,
intentionally so and vague, so that
anything
it says things like encouraging
hostility or well, who's going to decide
all that?
And um all of this so the kind of
Christianity that I'd like to see go
away
and I'd like to see it sort of bring
back a more traditional form of
Christianity
that prevailed during Christendom.
It well, what I call let's put it this
way. I've tried to coin a word. I call
it doormat Christianity and I think this
is the modern form of Christianity
whereby Christians are taught again in
keeping with what I'm saying, this
materialist idea to just be doormats,
okay? Christianity begins and ends by
you being a doormat. You're
non-confrontational, you lay down,
everyone walks all over you and then you
get to pat yourself on the shoulder and
say, "Hey, look, I'm virtuous. I'm
good." It's also a way of make
It's a way of make make turning of a
vice, cowardice, into a virtue, I think.
And that's why it's become very
prevalent, what I call doormat
Christianity. Doormat Christianity is
not going to stand up against Islam and
that's what we're seeing.
In fact, that kind of Christianity which
is completely about just being passive,
who do you think benefits from it most
of all? It's probably the more of an
enemy you are to Christianity, the more
the prevalent form of doormat
Christianity works and serves perfectly
to empower the opposite forces.
So, I think Christians need to recapture
and reclaim a sense of morality and a
sense of the metaphysical. These are the
building blocks. Without these, I don't
believe that let's say the Islam problem
cannot necessarily be addressed in and
of itself. You can't maintain a sort of
this current culture which with all its
confusions and sort of breakaway from
Christianity and then be able to resist
something like Islam. I think it's all
very interconnected. If you go back and
you can easily see this. Go back a
century to the way Western Europeans and
Westerners thought and Christians
thought, you wouldn't have this Islam
problem at all. Even if it existed, it
would immediately be solved. So, I think
there's a lot of paralysis going on
amongst Christians because they just
feel like like I said, uh the best they
can do is to just be just what they've
been taught and bred including like I
said by forces that don't like
Christianity. I saw a video um in the
Super Bowl a couple years ago and as
[snorts] you know, Super Bowl
commercials
Super Bowl commercials tend to
they're very prominent and they're very
mainstream.
And all it was was images of people
washing people's feet.
But for some reason, all the people who
were washing the feet looked like white
traditional Christian people. And all
the people getting their feet washed
were Well, one was a trans man, one was
obviously a like it was like on a
migrant border and it was an illegal
migrant. One was a woman committing an
abortion and or at an abortion center
and people are protesting but another
woman's washing her feet. And all and
one was a criminal and a policeman was
washing his feet.
And then it ended up by saying Jesus
didn't hate, he washed feet. And you can
just see that kind of message, how it is
completely geared to weakening
Christianity by also but making you
think you're being a good Christian.
Because there's no balance. Of course
Jesus washed feet, that's not my
argument, but there is a balance. Jesus
also hurled tables and made a court of
whips and drove people and livestock
out. So, there is a room I believe for
Well, the Bible says so, righteous
indignation that is at least funneled in
a proper way.
And all of that I guess is missing and
inasmuch as people don't get that, I I a
lot of this is futile and I'll end it by
what I call the two swords theology.
I just wrote a book that came out a few
months ago. It's called the two swords
of Christ, and it deals with the
military orders and their battles with
Islam, the the Templars and
Hospitallers. But there's a second
meaning to the title, and it's basically
in Luke where Christ says, "If he
doesn't have a garment, sell it and buy
a sword." And the disciples say, "Lord,
here are two swords." And he says, "That
is enough." Now, of course, to modern
day Christians, that means absolutely
nothing. It doesn't mean anything about
a real sword. But, of course, there's a
long and deep tradition, pre-modern,
especially medieval, understanding,
which is the two swords. One is
spiritual, which I think modern
Christians still accept, spiritual
warfare. But one is secular warfare,
okay? And um that's that was the whole
rationale for just war. That was the
whole rationale for um the Crusades,
which I'm sure a lot of people think are
not what they really were. Um
But so that kind of mentality, and
again, it's not about physical, not
necessarily literal. It's just about
being bold and militant, at least
vocally and in in your approach to
what's happening. Because if you look
back, you zoom out and see what's been
going on, it's just been one incremental
slow degrade. And no matter how many uh
no matter what people are saying or
doing or books or conferences, if you
look at the scale, it goes down little
It's like one step forward, three steps
back. And that's how it's been going.
So, I think in part with Christian
revival and the Islam threat, Christians
just need to again go to these first
things and really recapture a sense of a
morality that that is above and beyond
just physical considerations.
And once that is done, because like I
said, it's all interconnected, the Islam
question will become a lot easier to
answer almost um instinctively and very
natively. And that's it. Thank you.
>> [applause]
>> Raymond, we've seen a lot in the last
couple of weeks over Ramadan of the
real assertion of Islam in the public
space.
Do you think that it's legitimate
for the state institutions to actively
privilege Christianity and actually to
restrain the public assertion of Islam?
And what do you think is at stake if we
don't do that?
I think it's legitimate because that's
what every single other country and
civilization in the world does. They
prioritize their own religion, their own
culture, their own institutions. And
that's considered normal and accepted.
And you know, no Western country would
criticize Saudi Arabia for the way they
live, which is extremely draconian and
doesn't even have room for anyone else.
So, I definitely think every
civilization has at least its own right
to express fully its own Christian in
this case Christian heritage. And any
form even even forms of governments that
are based on Christianity. I don't think
there's anything wrong with that. Now,
of course, having invited so many
Muslims, that does cause a problem. Um
but at the same time, you could
[clears throat] it could just be
rectified by just having a Christian
revival. And it's just straightforward.
Again, this goes back to that doormat
mentality where, you know, we have to
hold back our religion to appease
someone else when nobody else would do
that and rightfully so because that's
their way. This is their land. This is
how they want to live. So, I don't think
the Brits should have any compunction
about resuscitating or resurrecting
their Christian civilization
irrespective of who lives around them.
This whole conference is based on the
premise that we're moving into a
post-liberal age, but some of the things
that some of you have talked about and
the way you've addressed these issues
seems to me to be very much fitting
within the liberal paradigm. So, you
says you talked about the sort of
ickiness of pre-liberal solutions like
deportations and the idea that we want
to make it okay and restore the liberal
neutrality of it's okay to be a
Christian, okay to think about our
history and our past in a positive light
rather than saying, "No,
we are the English, we are Christian,
and
this is what we think in a not in a
non-liberal, non-neutral sense. So,
we're we're talking about
you know, we don't want a
post-liberal world here, but we're still
operating within the paradigm of
liberalism. Raymond? Yeah, I actually
agree. That's obviously it's a
divergence of opinion, but I'm inclined
to agree with you in that this is kind
of what I was trying to say that
Christianity has sort of been co-opted
by secular liberalism and it's kind of
coincided with it because there are
similarities. The entire Christian
message of
you know, love, peace, tolerance,
turning the other cheek, but to a
certain degree we have to realize it's
now being weaponized against
Christianity. And that's the whole
point. There needs to be a balance. You
know, it's not it's not just the doormat
variety. There's also room for the whip
and cords analogy, which means there's
also time when Christians need to get
serious and
get their hands dirty as it were in this
sense. So, I'm in agreement with you and
therefore I protest that you're
associating me with your remarks.
And I rather agree with
with Raymond. My only point about
deportations is that they they may be
necessary and they are not the sole
policy
policy response to the
de-Christianization
and moral relativism of modern Britain.
And without wanting to sound too um
controversial, are we not being terribly
arrogant thinking that somehow we,
rather than God, can change the mood in
this country?
The one thing I haven't heard someone
say is all the movements of the spirits
have come from the edges. Wesley and you
know, when we had famously had revival,
it's actually about listening to God and
asking him how we should move rather
than us having all these theories about
how what's going to happen next. I don't
know how that looks like in the Anglican
Communion, but I would suggest that all
of us in the Communion of Saints would
be doing well to really listen to God's
call and actually if we did
that might happen again, that revival.
>> [applause]
>> I sympathize very much with what you
say, but you know, I'm reminded of the
old adage God helps those who help
themselves. And so on the one hand it's
also very vague and it sounds pious and
it's very appealing and I'm not against
it, but it also that kind of thinking
can lead to a lot of social paralysis
which I think has been going on actually
for quite many decades.
So I I think it's a symbiotic
relationship as it always is with God.
Okay, you know, maybe you of course God
starts and initiates, but you have to
work with him. So I'm all for listening
to God, but I also don't think that
should not become a sort of uh
uh call to just being in inactive and
you know, paralyzed and just waiting for
God to take care of everything. In fact,
I think that's the idea that to a
certain degree has led us to where we
are. Any final remarks? Final thoughts
um I just I just always because I like
to see things from a long historical
perspective and it's ironic I find that
the Western civilization Western world
is
super powerful today. Let's say compared
to Islam especially since that's the
main topic. You know, militarily,
economically, politically,
technologically. At no time in history
is it being more terrorized than by
Islam than today. Um you have to
remember in the medieval era Islam was
the behemoth and Europe was the
embattled tiny bastion of Christendom.
And they they managed to prevail. They
fought tooth and nail often times and
they articulated it through Christian
doctrine through as I mentioned two
swords theology and just war theology.
So, really when you look and think about
it, it's a lot of this and what you're
seeing is completely self-made,
self-done. It's initiated internally.
It's not because of external forces.
Because how can how can a society be at
its pinnacle, again, materially,
militarily, economically and be so
terrorized by by all intents and
purposes one of the weakest groups of
people? Islam is inherently weak today
compared to the West. They come as
migrants,
cap in hand, and then next thing you
know, the country's being taken over and
they have blasphemy laws and the native
people and the Christians feel like they
have to accommodate them. So, that's
pretty perverse development and I think
again, it's important to keep in mind
that it's 100% internal. These are not
external forces that have created this
and that is what we're talking about, of
course, the internal change that has led
to this, I believe and I think we're all
to various degrees saying, has to do
with the shrinkage or truncation of
Christendom.
Well, I think to to summarize, a lot is
at stake, the truth is at stake,
everything is at stake and we're not
going to succeed except by God's grace.
So, thank you very much to our speakers
and thank you all for your
contributions. [applause]
Bring back
the flame.
the fire
and the
righteousness.